prime minister has urged everyone to get
inoculated against covert 19
after the uk approved a jab in record
time
it comes after regulators gave the green
light to the vaccine produced by pfizer
and bayern tech
which has been shown to be up to 95
effective against the disease
well rollout of the vaccine will start
next week we'll give you a reminder of
the detail or some of the detail behind
the vaccine
well studies show that the fisa biotech
vaccine is up to 95
effective and works across all age
groups
the uk has ordered 40 million doses of
it already that's enough to vaccinate 20
million people
there are two doses needed of course
around 10 million doses are expected to
be available to be rolled out in the
coming weeks with eight hundred thousand
doses available from next week for
priority groups
uh big challenge then is going to be how
to distribute
and store it as this is the vaccine
which needs to be kept at
minus 70 to a minus 80 degrees
however it does remain stable for a
limited time between two and eight
degrees which allows it to be taken to
distribution centers
well the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization as this morning set out
a priority list
for recipients of the vaccine so who
will get it first while care home
residents and their carers
top priority closely followed by people
aged 80
and over and frontline healthcare
workers
next on the list everyone aged 75 to 79
people who are classed as clinically
extremely vulnerable
and then 70 to 74 year olds
next on the list will be people aged 65
to 69. sixth anyone aged 16 to 64
with underlying health conditions and
seventh
60 to 64 year olds well after this the
vaccine available to people aged
55 and uh and over followed by 50 to 54
year olds and finally everyone
under the age of 50.